or at least a paper copy of
um of a a draft Amendment to the bill
that I sent out if anybody does and I've
got some
extra what's that it's said what's that
it says 51 at the top 4 51 at the top to
differ it says the amended committee I
mean amended uh bill yeah yeah not just
um
so kind of as a a a recap I know there
were well there's a wide range of uh
concerns but I think some of the ones
that uh I know I heard from the
committee were related to
um you know if the op optometer are
going to be permitted to do additional
things the question is do they have
adequate training especially given as I
understand it that um the schools they
attended may not have been able to
either didn't provide the training or
didn't provide what might be viewed as
adequate training if for no other reason
than they uh were in states that did not
permit uh performing some of these uh
procedures on actual humans and so they
would not have had any live practice so
that was a concern and and
um there were also uh some views
that um some parts of the bill you know
the existing Bill had a lot of detail in
them especially around uh
glaucoma um and maybe that should be in
rule
making um but what I'd like to do is go
through the changes in the draft and you
know see what people have in the way of
comments or questions or any of that
question the chair certainly have we
provided copies of this to the uh guests
uh I haven't um actually somebody put
them up maybe on the table there people
them yep I think
yes I just have a comment on the
training piece yeah before we get into
dig into the meet sure I thought a lot
about this and it's it's sort of the
chicken in the egg story of no school's
going to engage in the training if the
opportunity isn't there to practice it
because they won't they're not likely to
Garner right
students
and and so if the board doesn't approve
it you know sort of the chicken in the
egg thing I think I think there is an
answer to that and and we'll get to it
good I'm anxious to hear it is it is an
issue yeah um
but as more states are permitting this
at least some of these then um I would
expect that would
change and if that causes a slow start
to optometrist being able to do that
here then that's what it is but that's
what'll happen so um anyway the first
change is on
uh bottom of page four mostly on page
and on this thing it's not red but I
made it bold and and a larger font so
hopefully it's visible and all this does
is there's um this is the section
on it's actually the last word on page
bottom very yeah
um and and it's uh related to an
optometrist licens to practice optomet
prior to uh
93 and some uh training they would have
to uh do and
that's that first sentence and last are
left in there one is that they have to
take the training and the last is the
board shall adopt rules under RSA
541a to carry out uh the provisions and
ensure safety of the public but it's
taking some of the uh
details out in the center section there
um
[Music]
repres M py and uh thank you Mr chair um
I I do appreciate the fact that we are
giving
provision or the word grandfa in so if
somebody graduated from school
January 1993 and these laser these
techniques were not even in this this
doesn't address that at all I mean this
is uh language that was in the bill
around the treatment of glaucoma that
they're permitted to do now when that
was my understanding is when that was
added there was an issue that there were
opthalmologists or optometrist sorry who
had not had the training for that and
this um would require them required them
to get that
training uh before they could do that
and um it's been left in I you know I
don't know that there there's anybody
else is going to get licensed newly who
uh had their uh their training or their
initial license uh you know prior to
93 but uh in case there is that's left
in here but the details on I this gives
Ru making authority to the board to come
up with the details of that
training um
and generally when we do that we we
limit the amount of that detail that's
in
statute that's what I was going to point
to is that the rule making is still left
to the Optometry board which has
functioned as a board uh to govern their
profession so that Ru making Authority
still at that so that they have the
ability to govern it that way make the
rule and not the legislators to say what
profession can do what professional
procedure correct although the
legislature will review whatever the
rules are through the ja car process but
the part of 5418 and uh representative
Simon you had a question or no
okay gr thank you so I just want to make
sure that we just um check this with as
was this also recommended by oplc that
we take this out
um is who's here from oplc
anyone all
right oh uh yeah he may be actually it's
um um Doug osterhout is supposed to be
here we can we can I can ask I'll just I
have the amendment suggested by
oplc that's included in here and we'll
get to that correct yeah so I don't
think it has anything to do no it's it's
a different
section okay uh but yeah when he comes
you want to ask that that's fine
um yep
sure uh thank you Mr chair repres Brown
so yes thank you um so what you are
deleting is what is currently in the law
correct
and just to make that the decision of
the board and not to have it in law
that's that's the point right right and
to have it go through Ru making which is
uh you know there's public comment and
all that that's in and the legislature
reviews it which is part of R making
okay and that's because it was thought
to be too too much in the weeds for the
law right and it may have there may have
been reasons um when this was new to do
that but that was 93's been a while and
there probably aren't representative
groda than you so last year when we went
through all these changes in oplc one of
the things that we did do was remove a
lot of these
dangling rules in statute and put them
in Ru making so that way if the rules
needed to change they could be they
could change and that so that I would
imagine that's also in line with
that right it's uh it can be updated as
things change more easily than having to
go through this process representative
manuti thank you so that clarified in
terms of giving the rule making to the
professional board and process for
license ing to oplc so that delineated
and increased the transparency of the
process correct thank you okay again uh
represent Brown thank you so for me to
be clear if as what it used to say what
it says in the law now is if you're
prior to January 1st
93 um you had to have a post-graduate
course of study but after
that it wasn't in the law so am I
assuming that a postgraduate course of
study after 93 was the norm I want to
make sure we aren't deleting something
that yes Chang we're getting head nods
over there and that was my understanding
that that date was there because the
schools of Optometry added it okay thank
you after that
point um I'm going to go through this to
address the the changes in this draft if
there are questions about other things
in here uh just you know let us know all
representative um Schmid thank you Mr
chairman so uh I I hope this this
process we're engaged in this morning is
going to be an interactive one with the
uh experts in Optometry and Opthalmology
that we have with us this morning so
that so that uh we don't talk over their
heads or disregard so I I hope that they
are going to be allowed to interact with
us as we do this because we know what
the ru making process is uh those of us
who were on the joint legislative
committee on administrative rules that
we call Jael car um Mr demur Mr Curtis
wherever you are over there uh so uh um
the thing is we know what they're what
we're talking about but to the degree
they they don't understand I I don't
want to talk over the top of their head
sure and and if uh members of the
committee subcommittee I should say have
uh questions you know that certainly
they
can but the rule the ru making process
is which I think a fair number of people
are familiar with but if you're not um
you know the board would propose D would
draft proposed rules um they have to go
out for public comment there's a period
of public comment they have to take
those into account and there's also a
public
hearing and um and once they settle on
the rules from that then there's a uh
Joint Committee of the house and the
Senate that reviews those rules and can
ask for changes and then there's a whole
whole process there
um and actually while we're still on
this section and Mr asout arrived uh
there was a question so if you could
come up
please introduce yourself and then
representative
and that's a um the draft that I put
together you know well with Consulting
with a bunch of people and we're going
through the changes in that draft and
then if people have other questions and
we're that's so representative broen
thank you uh Mr Oster how on page at the
bottom of page
four uh it's uh section8 on
Optometry uh paragraph
two the very last word
every continues to the next page and it
talks about optometrist that are
licensed before January 1st 19
1993 and those requirements for that and
we are striking that out and making sure
that that is part of the rules for under
RSA
541 so is that you could is that
something that you would not object to
from an office
standpoint good morning Douglas S howc I
realized they never actually introduced
myself uh the office wouldn't take a
position on that we wouldn't have a
problem with that okay thank you
okay um represent Moody thank you Mr
chair um another question in terms of um
the same section um the ru making and
the licensing are two processes that
oplc is in charge of one and the other
one is for rulle making for the board is
that um this is clear with the language
language would oplc see that as a I
think it's clear I'm just looking at it
now I I think it's clear I especially in
Reading context of the rest of the
Practice Act and RSA 310 I I don't think
there'd be any confusion from our
perspective okay thank you okay um I'd
like to go on to um the next change in
this draft I'd like to go through the
change to this draft and then if there's
other
questions um I'd like to address them
then if possible so now at page seven
near the top of page
s um this is uh really the uh the most
substantive change and you know as I
mentioned before there were concerns
about you know optometrist not have had
not having um adequate training due to
the circumstances to perform some of
these
procedures
um and so and this section is um
examinations and licenses authorization
perform alamic
procedures and you know it says unless
otherwise specified this chapter the
board will have the authority to
determine what constitutes the practice
Optometry um and that by person's
lessons that chapter and that was in the
original bill but it goes consistent
with curriculum of nationally accredited
schools and colleges of
Optometry and the board of Optometry
there's an editing thing there but and
the board of Optometry shall adopt rules
under RSA 541a establishing
credentialing certific certification
which shall fulfill before a person sh
be fulfilled before person may be
certified to perform opic procedures for
the practice Optometry and then it lists
a number of things that have to be done
as part of that rule
making and the first is identification
categorization of optomic procedures for
the practice of Optometry I mean the
thing
is you know there's there are likely to
be optometrists that aren't interested
in doing all of the new procedures they
maybe they wouldn't do any of them maybe
they do some and requiring all
optometrists to have the training and
everything if they're not going to do it
I don't think makes sense and so this is
to have Cate have them create categories
of them um you know establish an
application process for certification to
perform
them um and and one that met some key
concerns is establishment of minimum
education training and live experience
requirements for C certification to
perform such procedures and that would
be done through Ru Mak which you know
everybody has every anybody uh has input
and can comment on um it didn't seem to
make sense to put specific numbers or
hours or whatever in here I don't think
we have the expertise for that exactly
but it does require that they have
training for the particular classes of
procedures they're going to do including
uh live training
represent M py thank you Mr chair I
think your Chain of Thought is very much
in align to our discussions we had
earlier with
the public hearing so I have questions
to two folks one is uh
Opthalmology represent representative
and
optometrist it's the same question are
all
opthalmologist performing all of the
proc procedures or their
specialization under Opthalmology
license similarly optometrist not all
optometrist are performing every single
procedure is their specialization
available if I am an optometrist and I
want to just do the latest you know I
was trained to do just the laser
procedure then it's upon me to get
certification similarly with the
Opthalmology I know with the medical
field you have the specialization track
where you can do an additional
fellowship and you know and so you can
super specialize but this will help so
is that inexistent right now so I think
uh Dr ricardi if if you could answer
that and I'm sure we'll get back to you
good morning thank you my name is Kim
lardi I'm an opthalmologist practicing
in Manchester and I'm the current
president of the New Hampshire Society
of I Physicians insurgents um to answer
your question representative um all
opthalmologists as we complete our
Residency program we do perform
basically all of we experience every
procedure as residents and we are
required to perform them as an assistant
as an observer and as a primary Serv
um technically we can do all of the
procedures when we graduate residency um
the majority of us may choose to do a
fellowship um to further subsp
specialize and with how specific and
detailed medicine in general and the eye
have become um for example I learned
retinal procedures as a resident most
Retina Specialists do an additional
2-year Fellowship so so I generally do
not perform any retinal procedures I
refer those to my colleagues who have
done a retina Fellowship um and we have
several different one to twoe
fellowships uh that uh many people
pursue okay thank you and um follow up
to that is the is that just the practice
of opthalmologists uh if they're going
to specialize in some area they're going
to do a fellowship and get further
training or is that required either
statute or rules um it's not required
okay but you would have difficulty say
obtaining hospital privileges to perform
certain surgeries had you not completed
a fellowship and demonstrated you know a
a case log with experience okay thank
you and oh you have a followup sorry um
so hospital privileges in in patient
surgery or Hospital surgery is one
and many of these procedures now the
advancement of technology has um
provided opportunity for the
opthalmologist to do outpatient in your
office kind of thing does that
require um
board uh certification or
authorization so once once you move a
procedure into your office um the
oversight
is um the oversight of say a hospital
credentialing committee is gone um a lot
of us operate at outpatient surgery
centers um which are not Hospital
Affiliated however they do have similar
credentialing
processes who who does the credentialing
then the board of
Opthalmology of the board of
Opthalmology who credentials the
outpatient currently oh I I other than
we are board certified we're licensed in
the state um the oversight is the Board
of
Medicine um U just yeah
yeah I think the the question that we
would need clarification on is we
understand the hospital you you ain't
going to be able to do that if there
unless you've been sufficiently trained
and credential and so forth these out
these centers that you were referring to
the question
is who credentials
them and but more specifically in my
case is you reference the fact that some
uh practitioners may be doing this in
their
office
um and and uh if we're going to permit
optometrist to do this then we have to
have some kind of oversight that we know
that the person has had the necessary
training and that they have the
necessary Neary skill and experience so
that it can be done safely on the
patients of New Hampshire that's my
concern and I'm sure it is of my
colleagues as well I agree who is
checking the the the the procedure if
it's done in the office of the
opthalmologist and it would have to be
similarly overseen credentialed and safe
in the case of an optometrist doing the
procedure theoretically right yep I mean
if we if we go there yes and that is one
of our issues with the bill is there so
can you speak to how how it's how it's
checked on uh if if an opthalmologist is
doing it at his or her office who is uh
who is controlling for quality and
safety in in those instances for
Opthalmology then we're going to have to
know that the optometrist is going to be
similarly capable I don't think some of
these are clearly surgical things that I
don't think very many optomet going to
want to get to that level of of of thing
we're we're talking about a limited
expansion of Optometry not the full
boore full
board uh right so yeah I need to have
more more Buy in from you guys with
regard to how this is going to be how
it's done as a moment for
opthalmologists and how it's going to be
done for optomet well just a moment can
I jump in here yeah they not they're not
going to answer optometrist questions
we're asking you how do optimists who
cred who is the one that gives the the
optomologist credentials for practicing
in their office or practicing outside in
an outpatient clinic that's the qu from
your field how do you do it so um we
have all completed a uh Residency
program in Opthalmology with minimum
training require requirements that
program has been certified by the acgme
which is the American College of
graduate medical
education um this provides reassurance
that we meet a minimum competency um
demonstrating that we're competent on
live
patients um and then once we have
completed that the Board of Medicine as
they're issuing our license is reassured
that we have de demonstrated a
minimal
competency in the procedures within our
field follow up follow up so the Board
of Medicine license licenses you get
from the Board of Medicine allows you to
practice in your office and on an
outpatient basis yes out patient clinics
is that right correct and then in
addition to that if you if you want to
practice in a hospital you have to meet
their criteria and they okay and that's
where hospital privileg it's an
additional credential
process that answers our question thank
you all right thank you thank
you oh wait hang on another question
represent Brown sorry thank you sorry I
always need clarification
apparently um so that would be the case
probably for any
certification across any any industry
you're certified to this by the license
ing agency you can do it wherever you
want unless somewhere you go has
stricter requirements yes does that make
sense that's what we're all saying right
thank you all right thank one more
represent G and just just another brief
clarification so what you're saying is
uh in terms of Specialties specializing
um in any of those areas you've been
minimally trained in there is no
credentialing that happens Beyond um the
normal licensing for your
occupation that applies to the
credentialing if you're working in your
office or in one of these centers that
outside the hospital realm is that
correct did I understand that right
correct there there's certain procedures
that you might be required to carry
additional malpractice insurance
for uh so anyone
else okay thank
you okay um i' like the same question
for the optom if they can answer we're
working on it here um I I probably uh Dr
Sawyer uh would be
best and
uh have to be yeah yeah actually yeah
you almost have to eat it got it thank
you um if you could go over uh this
section the changes to this section um
and I don't know if
there's a copy uh I I'm I believe I'm
from I've got that one okay yes I
believe I have it here in front of me
okay so again my name is Dr Angelique
soyer I am an optometrist and practice
owner in North Conway and Berlin New
Hampshire um I am a past president of
the New Hampshire um Association of
Optometry um so in answer to your
question first um
all optometrists coming out of school at
this time have the training and the
education what they may not all have
coming out of school is that live
patient experience this amendment is
specifi specifically requiring that
there will be a live um requirement
necessary some of the students coming
out of school will have the training but
if they do not plan to go on to do these
procedures they might not seek out
getting that live patient experience if
they're in a state that has the
authority to do that they will likely
have that experience as part of their
education and as more states have that
it will become inherent that more are
graduating with it whether they're
seeking it out or not um while we're
still in a a period where um there are a
number of schools that are in states
where that is not something they can get
at their school on a regular basis um it
is incumbent on them to seek that out
during the fourth year of the um
Optometry training program is entirely
in clinical practice and students have
the opportunity to choose where they do
that clinical practice so if somebody is
planning to go to a state or they're
wanting to in their future perform these
procedures they can seek out rotations
in the states where they will be able to
get that live
experience within the four years of
optometry school which includes that
year of clinical rotations um we have
learned the basics what may be missing
is that l
um experience the additional residency
is a for Optometry is akin to the
fellowship for an opthalmologist if they
want to then go on and specialized and
just do retina they may do an additional
Fellowship in Optometry because we know
from day one that we are specializing in
the eye all four years of our training
are focused on the eye and how we are
going to be treating all of these
conditions how these systemic condition
relate to the eye in Opthalmology and
Medicine your four years of medical
school you don't know that you're going
to be an opthalmologist so only when you
begin your residency are you then now
becoming an opthalmologist and beginning
your more specialized training in that
residency process so their residency is
very
different to what an Optometric
residency is our Optometric residency is
more akin to their Fellowship where we
have all that basic training within the
Optometric education and you could then
go on to specialize if you wanted to be
a pediatric opthalmologist if you wanted
to do specialty contact lenses um if you
wanted to do vision therapy for people
who have low vision um those are the
more specialized Optometric residencies
so um that um I hope answers your
question there as far as the type of
training and where some will come out of
school having this training may not have
the live experience and may not pursue
that if that's not something that
they're planning to do in their practice
and one thing I'd like to add I back is
um I hadn't covered is uh section two on
page seven starting line
23 it's no optometrist shall practice
under this section unless the
optometrist has submitted to the board
of Optometry evidence of satisfactory
completion of all requirements for
specific procedures and the board has
certified the Optometry is qualified so
if they haven't
completed the uh uh training
requirements in the uh categories of
optim op AIC procedures they want to do
um then they're not permitted to do
them uh represent MRA py thank you Mr
chair so is there a minimum hours
required by the Optometry specialization
fellowship or whatever you call that
residency or for specialty especially in
operative the newer Technologies that's
available laser or um if I can just add
something and then um so setting that is
is given to them with rulemaking however
would I answer the question but also
address there's I know there's a um
accrediting Association for the schools
and um which the chapter mentions and um
so do they have such requirements yes so
the schools um are all accredited by the
um the ACO that is our accrediting body
for all these schools and and colleges
of Optometry um at this point and this
is why we didn't have concrete answers
to be able to give last week is that
accrediting body does not have a minimum
number of procedures Nationwide because
there are so many schools that are not
able to do this so that is why in this
amendment and through rul making there
is a live requirement and and it there
is a um a minimum number of procedures
that will need to be done for somebody
to come to New Hampshire with time that
that will become the norm across the
country in all of the schools as they
have the ability to get to meet those
minimums um but at this time because
there is um there is not that ability
there is not the live experience minimum
by the acoe um on average the Optometry
schools um we spend about 2500 hours in
classroom and lab training and about
2500 hours in clinic
follow up follow thank you uh Mr chair
thank you for indulging in the time um
so from my recollection there are 24
schools of Optometry in this country and
the two closest to our state we don't
have any in our state correct are they
doing these trainings are you know if
you're able to draw from the neighboring
states close to us are they doing these
trainings are these available for the
optometrist the two schools in
Massachusetts are not able to perform
live experiences on patients because
Massachusetts does not have the ability
however students from those schools can
do their clinical rotations in states
that have that ability to get that live
experience follow up which are those
States close by or the the closest at
Indiana and and I think that goes to uh
some of them maybe represent Gould if I
may be remembering correctly about the
chicken egg thing I mean this may grow
slowly because of those kind of
limitations but at least it allows that
to
proceed uh representative
groa so if
a let's assume that the board of
Optometry is set up okay and it's doing
the ru making as it should so
then with they be then the accrediting
body for optometrist in New
Hampshire so the optometrists in
graduating would still need to um
graduate from an accredited school y um
they still pass their licensing exams
particularly if somebody were to then go
on and want to do these
procedures then they need to meet the
minimum requirements that have been laid
out by the board and the board is aware
of this amendment they're aware of what
is being what will be required to be
done in rulemaking um there are some
draft languages that are already being
put together as to what that's going to
look like um to to make sure that that
is robust and and that they're prepared
to do that safely and yes slowly this is
going to take a long time for it to go
through rulemaking it's going to take a
long time um for people to get these
experiences I don't Envision any
optometrist in the state is going to be
doing this for at least a year before
anybody's actually able able to be doing
any of these things in practice um the
board is um you know adamant that they
correctly I think I'm I had a followup
but I I lost it so I'll come back to it
represent
Brown uh thank you Mr chair so this
might be a a question for you or
attorney arer how or or anyone that
wants to answer it I suppose if I'm
reading this correctly
it's saying that optometrists will make
decisions for their practice about op
opthamologist procedures would that be
similar to would that be similar to an
electrician making a decision for a
plumber no no Opthalmic procedures means
relating to the eye it is not
specifically an opthalmologist procedure
or an Optometric procedure so that term
in um that line where you say to perform
Opthalmic procedure
simply means relating to the
eye
okay nothing in this statue or anywhere
within the bill impacts how Opthalmology
practices they're entirely within the
Board of Medicine okay and follow up or
another question um yeah first I'm going
to point out that um if you look
at um under Section six
um it starts on page two but a lot of
it's on The Following on page three and
then four it it actually um provides
some limitations
on what the optometrist can do and
there's quite a few things that they're
not permitted to do and since that's in
statute uh the rul making by the board
of Optometry could not permit them to do
it yeah and I have more questions on
that after through the Section okay um
so
yeah I know I do have a follow up follow
y as these are then Opthalmic and not
opthalmologic procedures the
requirements for live experience don't
have to match those obviously so that
would be the board will be setting live
experience requirements for non optim
opic procedures is that correct yes for
for the optometrist to perform these
procedures would be set by the board
however their intention at this point is
to have it match the minimums of what is
required by opthalmologists coming out
of residency the
acgme um which is five five five laser
five of each of the lasers and and 55
and four are the uh the number of
procedures for the lasers that are
required minimums for Opthalmology
coming out of residency and so the board
of Optometry plans to mirror that in Ru
making thank you okay representative
gold thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question it's pretty
simple one um regarding the terminology
live experience requirements I just
wanted to you use that term so I'm
assuming that is a common term in your
field yes okay yes and then the um next
line down on line 19 on page 7 uh
protocols for proctoring yes can you
just explain to me what proctoring is so
that would be for those who have been
out of practice to get that live
experience um and so that would be
performing procedures under somebody who
is trained in performing those
procedures already be it an optometrist
an opthalmologist be it um in New
Hampshire at a school in a state that
those procedures are already being
performed thank you thank you uh rep
represent gr did you have a question
thank you um Mr chair I just have a
question so do optometrist only practice
office no optometrists can practice
elsewhere um some optometrists do um
have hospital privileges and and take
emergency call for hospitals um it's
rare the majority do not the majority of
care is provided in the office I don't
know of any that have any privileges at
ambulatory surgical centers because we
aren't doing surgical procedures even
the things that we're looking for here
um while there's nothing that would
prevent them from being able to do it in
a surgical center if that's where the
laser was located and that's where they
wanted to have it done and they wanted
to pursue that pathway of of
credentialing um what we're aiming for
Here We largely envisions optometrists
doing in their office these are in
office procedures okay thank you thank
you and U representative mipi did you
have a question thank you uh Mr chair
just basic confusion that keeps coming
up optom Board of Optometry exists and
it's not a new board that's going to be
formed it exists independently of the
medical board which is Opthalmology is
part of yes exactly the board of
Optometry has been around for over a
hundred years it is independent it has
never been under the Board of Medicine
um the only thing changing from here is
one there is a name change um it has
been referred to as the board of
registration on an optometry rather than
just the board of Optometry so s SP 440
does to name it analogous to all the
other professional boards and what we're
talking about here is that Ru making
Authority and moving more into their
ability to control through ruem rather
than having it spelled out specifically
in statute follow up Mr check how often
does the board of Optometry meet I
believe it's every six weeks every every
six week which I haven't
seen I don't know if I have time I will
at some point yep um what I'd like to do
is the the next section it's Rel very
much related to this if you look at the
very bottom of page seven and it goes on
to page
eight um it's an
addition that says uh and this is in the
um disciplinary action section of the
statute it adds uh that performing
authorized Opthalmic procedures without
certification based upon the
requirements outlined in 327 colon 6D
which is the part we just went through
shall be grounds for suspension or
revocation of an optometry license Andor
certification to perform authorized
optomic procedures so just to make it
clear that that uh they're not to
perform procedures that they haven't
been you know certified by the
requirements of the board and that if
they do they can be disciplined for it
uh let's see anybody in the verb much py
thank you so many questions popping up
um so in terms of optometrist um you
also have to carry a liability
malpractice liability all those
insurances yes does that change with the
specialization if if you are doing
Advanced procedures there is additional
coverage that you need to carry your
your malpractice or liability provider
needs to be aware they specifically ask
you when you're renewing your policy are
you in a state where this is permitted
are you performing these procedures
find so when you and the optometrist and
opthalmologist work together hand in
hand are there any time when the
optometrist is doing the advanced
procedure that liability is transferred
to the opthalmologist if you're on the
team no no
okay okay um so um are there any other
questions at this point for
um for Dr Sawyer Sawyer thank
you well Mr chairman we we're seeing
audience excuse me excuse me I I'm
allowed to participate fully here I
don't have a vote but I'm allowed to
participate fully when I see Hands being
raised or heads shaking out there I want
to find out what they are referencing
this is
not we we are we have our role to play
here but they have their role and when I
see hands and they're not responded to
I'm not satisfied with that procedure
excuse me but when they're raising their
hands I want to he have them be
recognized so we can address the issues
that they are
raising thank you all right
um we'll get to that in a moment do you
have you have another
question I do have a question
that uh I need for clarification for
myself before we get off of this section
so during the hearing if I recall I
heard that there's 220 and correct me
any one if I'm approximately
220 codes for up up up mologic
procedures the
optometrist asked if they could do that
they would like to do 44 of
those
so in this amendment do you see that you
procedures the way that the amendment is
it could be up to those 44 the board in
rule
making has the opportunity and at this
point the intention to further narrow
that down um they uh as part one
indicates the identification and
categorization of procedures they would
spell out what those procedures are um I
do not believe their intention is to CL
include all 44 of those procedures
within the rule making and followup sir
follow up thank you for entertaining me
here um and those 44 you would say are
Opthalmic procedures yes okay if anyone
disagrees with that or if I can clarify
anymore don't take that personally not a
problem let let the brain know here I'd
appreciate that okay thank you okay um
before we move on to anything else
anybody else have any further questions
at this point for um Dr
Sawyer okay thank you thank you very
much and
um if I mean there were were some
questions from that side of the room if
comment you need to turn the mic on and
I do I apologize thank you um I'm not
that loud so uh thank you I will try to
be quick didn't get a chance to look at
this amendment beforehand can introduce
yourself first please I'm Katherine
mirando I'm an opthalmologist here in
town at conquered ey Center um and I'm a
glaucoma a specialist I did my training
at masser I'm two years out of practice
so hopefully I can well remember
training and speak maybe uh to those
aspects of um of what's being addressed
in this bill so I think one thing that's
important is that and that's quite novel
is that there's no model in any other
state for minimums or criteria in the
training two of the 24 states that allow
allow um of residencies that allow
Hands-On training what we heard at the
hearing was that there is no um minimum
right now for the the number of patients
and the way in Opthalmology we determine
competency is more than just minimums
because you could have a minimum number
of procedures and still not be competent
with them the acgme actively works with
these programs and residencies to sure
that the residents are meeting criteria
have active meetings make sure that the
um professors training are qualified
themselves and actively evaluating
before they would um graduate someone we
don't have an optimetric School in New
Hampshire um so it's not that this bill
would allow that training to begin here
and we have we have it's very know like
we have no other state to even look to
for how this is being done currently
I've tried I know I'm not an optometrist
I'm trying to learn as quickly as I can
about the um depth and breadth of their
training but I don't pre presume to know
exactly what they go through but I I can
say that I don't see another state to
even look to to understand how we would
implement this here and I also think
that in terms of patient safety which is
the reason that I canceled my clinic
this morning um I don't understand the
outcomes reporting and and way to
measure measure safety because we know
we brought someone to the hearing who
was blinded by one of these lasers yet
there were zero reported outcomes so I
think we don't even have a a good system
in another state to look to where they
are having minimum criteria where they
are reporting safety um and that
minimums alone are not enough to
determine competency at least in the way
we do it in um in the medical uh side of
things and then we also had a letter for
speaking to to the um insurance coverage
OMC the major supplier or major um
provider of malpractice insurance um had
a letter that they did not support
extending these uh surgical surgical
coverage to
optometrist um most opthalmologists are
even uh covered under OMC so I don't
know how if if there would try to be
some type of um merger together of
Opthalmology and Optometry and training
how we would even be able to help um
supervise I just I I'm not seeing a
pathway forward in this amendment and it
was just presented moments ago but I've
tried to look as much as I can into the
training I just don't see
um understand a safe way that we're
considering how we're considering
patient safety with this okay thank you
I'm I'm gonna um ask um Dr Sawyer to to
give her perspective but but um are
there yeah are there any questions
before that uh represent M py thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question and uh thank you for being here
um I know it's difficult uh but I
understand that the schools in Optometry
has just started this or 10 years ago or
you know in the the two schools that are
training in the specialty has only
started 10 years years ago 15 years when
the laser started with the Opthalmology
too um so that was my point in terms
of the it didn't exist so the
malpractice insurance for Opthalmology
the company that does that is not even
aware of the fact that this could be
something coming up for Optometry so you
know the Optometry will they cover or
not cover
that is a if they're not able to get the
malpractice coverage how can they even
practice because that is the critical
thing right so there is one at least
from my point of view that's uh there is
a check and balance I believe from the
liability don't you agree well there's
more than just OMC uh which is the
insurance provider that I was mentioning
so I'm sure there would be um
potentially ways around that and then
OMC did submit a letter that was
included in the packet I'm so sorry I
don't know off hand um but but OMC did
submit a letter with the knowledge of
this um this bill being put forward so
it is with the newest information that
was provided to them um and I think that
even if this is a newer concept being
put forward to have optometrist trying
to do surgeries we should have a
framework in place for safety and
training before we are out practicing
and certifying um providers to do
surgery on patients which is currently
happening but in other states but
there's
no competency criteria to attain that
status so it seems like the cart is a
far ahead of the
horse
um actually a representative gr thank
you
so I'm not sure you understand because
the cart is not in front of the horse
okay there's no cart even there's no
horse all we have is what we're saying
is that the optometrist will form their
criteria to proceed to do these
procedures they may be different than
the way you perform them but when you
look at all the things that you
do let's say of what sliver of the pie
procedures that they want to do what's
sliver of the pie I guess I do about 20
every two weeks uh not you per se but
I'm talking about of all the things that
opthalmologist do yes what percentage
are these procedures
and what is the percentage of risk in
these procedures are we asking them like
for example
I'm using this as a hypothetical
example if I want to take a splinter out
of my finger right I'm going to go to my
primary care physician and they can take
the splinter out they're not going to
send me to a
surgeon right so if I go to an
optometrist or my optometrist and I need
one of these procedures
done I am
I if they are accredited by the they're
bored to do so because they have done so
many of these procedures and it's not up
to we do not look at what other states
do we look at what is right for our
state that's what we decide we base it
on what we want we don't look at what
other states do okay and one of the
requirements that became very apparent
in the hearing is that
live um clinical experience was required
and we went to the excuse me
the acgm and we use those right so you
can't say that we have no criteria or
that the cart is before the horse
because we have set up the criteria you
may not agree with it that may be the
issue but don't say that we haven't said
anything or that we haven't done that
because we we are doing that that's this
process does this make sense to you
know I I apologize I'm I'm I think that
is new to this amendment which I'm just
seeing now is this introduction of these
um not just introducing the ideas of
minimum so I completely appreciate that
I'm just I truly am here just for
patient safety I don't in any way think
that I'm sure there are plenty of
optometrists that are much smarter than
I am it's really just a pathway of of
providing Safe Care and so I'm trying to
make sure I understand that and that's
what we're discussing today but um and I
apologize if I sound first of all I have
I have allergies so I don't normally
sound like this but also
[Music]
um we have I mean one of the reasons why
we are on this committee is that we care
about Public Safety as well we get Bill
after Bill after Bill about
licensing at the same time we are not we
are we are also sympathetic to hurdles
that could be put in the the path of
others who are competent to do to do it
but others are concerned and won't let
them so we are we're going to test that
hurdle and we're gonna that's our job
that's what we do at the same time we
weigh that and we weigh Public Safety so
I just want you to understand that and I
appreciate that you're here for Public
Safety but we're here for that too does
that make sense makes perfect sense and
I appreciate it and so I'm I think then
I am complete agreement that we should
looking at the competency criteria and
how to go about in ensuring that and I
just don't um I'm not I'm not sure what
the pathway is to that I don't um see a
a plan that makes sense yet so I'm glad
that we're that's what's um we're trying
to understand um I knew had said one oh
and then safety I guess that's where I
have maybe the most understanding and
that was my testimony previously but
these are not like we moving a splinter
irreversible um just a moment one one
thing I will um kind of tried to explain
it before
but in the section where it's talking
about you know determining what the
procedures are um what the process is
what the education training and live
requirements are and all of that um you
know what it means when it says that's
going to be done through 541a rule
making is that it's not that the
optometrists on their own are going to
cook up whatever they want and go forth
and do whatever they want um you know
that is open to public comment and
review including by um opthalmologists
and everybody else in the in the state
or country I guess um so part of the
process is
that I suspect there will be a lot of um
scrutiny of whatever proposed rules um
they're they come up with and then
that's going to be reviewed by um you
know the legislature as well and so uh
we're not telling them go out and do
whatever you want that that's not what
this process is um Reverend
Simon thank you Mr chair yeah just for
clarification purposes because it is
very Dynamic situation it's changing
constantly so I appreciate the position
that you're in with new information
coming at you um all of the time but in
agreement with you just real briefly
what you're looking at in that amendment
is the skeleton essentially we set the
skeleton and then through Ru making
they'll fill in all of the details of of
what that pertains to I did ask at the
last meeting uh for the optometrist
board to give me an a sense an idea of
what that rule making process might look
like what kind of um requirements that
they're putting in place um I've
received that which I was appreciative
of um it's right now I mean it's subject
to change but it's about three pages
long and it does take into consideration
the things that you're you're talking
about so beyond minimum standards which
it does have minimum standards in it it
does also have a perceptor ship which
maybe somebody will have the ability to
talk to um so that somebody with
experience is going to be overseeing the
training and putting their stamp of
approval that they are actually
competent in doing the procedure not
that they've just done five but they can
actually do it well with Public Safety
in mind uh and there is also a reporting
requirement for procedures that are done
back to the board so that we can keep an
eye on um that sort of thing so once
again that's not what we'll handle here
in this particular place unfortunately
the process will be longer um if this
bill goes forward because we will be
pushing it over to Ru making um and then
all of those components will come up and
you'll have an opportunity at that point
to speak any concerns you might have
with the very specific rules that are
coming up in those categories um so just
so you know it's not make a break it
here um so that was all I wanted to say
thank that's all interesting information
so I'll get back to you thank you Mr
chairman so the chair stated
earlier toward the beginning one of the
things that we always have to keep in
mind is we are not opening the entire
Museum
here we
are considering expanding what
optometrist can do in certain specific
areas not not the entirety of what
opthalmologists do
but certain specific things and that's
all we're talking about and the chair
wisely alluded to that earlier on so
that's what we're trying to do
is what I'm trying to see is to get at
the things that the optomet are asking
to do to see which of those things you
say absolutely not or possibly that this
could be a workable area in which
optometrist could be sufficiently
trained and credentials and so forth um
and in which it would improve access in
the entirety of New Hampshire and that
is as representative grotus said earlier
that's our concern what can we do for
the benefit of the people in the state
of New Hampshire that would also
benefit the optometrist in in expanding
their practice but not opening the
entire Museum as I said
so and and and the chair alluded to that
and we have to keep that in mind we're
not talking about everything and and
representative Simon said we were
creating the he called it a skeleton but
the the amendment if we adopt it will
permit uh the the rule writers with the
involvement of stako stakeholders and
practitioners to develop the necessary
rules in that one L limited area or
small areas that we are specifically
talking about that's all we're not
trying to get into the whole ocean here
just one little cup of it representative
gr thank you um sorry represent M py
thank you Mr chair thank you for the eye
contact so I knew it was you're refering
to
me um one more uh in terms of um your
concern I understand and we don't want
to uh change the you know upset the
apple card to say but we can't be status
coal either the reason one of the big
reasons
for uh me as a legislator this is
important for is the fact that we have
Workforce shortage we have access
shortage and we don't have medical
school got public Medical School dental
school Optometry or any of those in our
state how do we attract new Workforce as
we age as the state ages we need more
Workforce and how do we attract there
might be this special caveat to get
attract more you know well
trained uh folks to come in rather than
putting um
obstacles so I'm looking at this as do I
want to age in this state or do I have
to move out to be able to afford
anything so that that's a critical thing
so that is also another side to it which
enables newer coming
out uh
graduated with not a burden of debt that
they can't do anything have to go to a
better paying
state so those are all the things that
come into play um just really quickly uh
representative manood I hope you want to
stay in New Hampshire it's beautiful and
um I think everyone here loves it uh in
the packet on page 19 we had a diagram
of the the number of optometrists um
that increased by 40 almost 46% from
2013 to 2023 whereas the population
increased by um 5.6% so it seems like a
lot there are a lot of optometrist
coming to the state I don't think we
have any access data for the lasers that
I think and when we were mentioning the
small piece of the P I think you know as
active amendments are coming through my
inclination or understanding is that
what what is wanted are three lasers the
yag Pi SLT um uh and uh yag cap and
those are
elective lasers they're not emergencies
and um access to those is they're
they're just not emergencies so it's not
needing to be seen within a week they
are I I don't have any data of access
issues with those three specific lasers
that are being addressed in this bill so
I'm a little unclear on how this bill
solves issues with access it would be
interesting if there was Data showing
um I don't know um i' I'd like if um
either Dr soy or Donahue want to comment
you thank you um a couple of things that
I will just respond to um first omic is
um their from their website it was
started by opthalmologist the credential
and they they um I'm sorry not
credential but they provide liability
coverage for opthalmologists so um from
their website our mission is to serve
the needs of the members of the American
Academy of Opthalmology so I'm not
surprised that they wouldn't support or
um cover an optometrist um but in all of
the states that optometrists are
performing these they have no problems
in securing malpractice
insurance um the it was brought up that
um there are no states to model after
there are states to model after that do
require live requirements Kentucky
requires live practice um live cases
before practicing independently um most
recently South Dakota passed this um
just this year and they also have a live
minimum requirement of patient cases so
there are other states um we will look
to those States but we will may take it
even further beyond that we want to as
as I said the board wants to do this
safely slowly um effectively and do it
right the first time and we may become
the model that other states then model
after to do it right um the uh
optometrists yes are still coming to the
state part of that is because there are
more optometrists that are coming out as
I had mentioned in my testimony last
week the um rate of opthalmologists is
projected to continue declining um I
believe somebody had asked um in that
hearing and we did um determined that it
is projected that optometrists will grow
by at least 9% over the next 10 years so
there will continue to be optometrists
available um our concern is that we want
the best of the best to want to come
here to be practicing at that high level
um and and to be able to to fully
utilize the education um that they have
um lastly as far as the access issue
while these procedures um may not be
emergency um they they may be elective
um we don't want to wait until our
patients are in a state of emergency to
have to get these done
um we had a case of a patient who you
you know suffered terribly um for quite
six six weeks um when she had already
been in her surgeon's office and was not
treated at that day and she had one eye
and while it was not an emergency it was
an elective procedure so she can wait
six weeks and her life was miserable in
those six weeks so um we want to be
proactive and give patients access um
there will still absolutely be cases of
these same procedur that I could do that
I will choose not to do in more complex
cases where I'm going to recommend that
they travel the distance to somebody who
is going to be able to handle a higher
risk case that is part of our
professional ethics and our training and
what we do is making those judgment
calls um I think that covers what I
wanted to respond to were there any
other questions that you any questions
from uh
subcommittee okay thank you thank you I
I'd like to um hang on a minut we'll get
back
uh Mr osterhout if you can come
up and
um this is on page eight starting at
line seven and the reason I'm asking him
to come up and talk about this is this
language was from oplc at their
request Mr chairman when when we have a
hand
raised but but the thing
is if we get into something else then
she may forget question I mean a brief
response I do not want to get an
extended debate about all of this so one
person a brief response to whatever is
causing the hand raising you need to
come
up I will keep this very very brief but
in response to the particular case that
was mentioned here of this woman needing
to wait 6 weeks after she had already
seen the surgeon the primary the reason
that that happens is because we have to
obtain prior authorization for the
procedure and if we truly want to
improve access there are other issues at
hand that need to be addressed I
understand unfortunately that's the
Commerce Committee and not us I just
wanted to bring that to your attention
have enough to deal with that that that
would solve a lot of problem thank you
for that information thank you thank you
that's very important
to uh
Insurance that's right that's I don't
need that
no um anyway if you know this was I
added this at your request so why don't
you explain what this is about I think I
know but I'm sorry page eight it starts
at line
seven so this was just uh reading in the
bill I think a week ago I just noticed
some of the language conflicted with the
procedures laid out in RSA 310 and so
this proposal very straightforward is
just to bring those in line with the PLC
statute okay if you can just mention
some of them sure General sure um so I'm
on line seven or I'm in line nine uh
permits are now issued by the office
pursuant to RSA
3104 Roman numeral 2 parentheses
c
um
again with line 13 the office issues
that
permit going through um line 22 on to
23 it says the business complies with
all lawful directions and requirements
for information from the Board of
Pharmacy and the board of
Optometry of all states in which it
conducts business the only reason I
added suggested language or other
applicable licensing Authority where
here some states it's board some states
their advisory it it just it's a
catch-all language kind of thing so
whatever the licensing Authority would
be in the other state
that was my goal here and I think that
was it for my requests okay any
questions represent mipi thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so uh the 21 to 23 that is in case of a
reciprocity coming from another state
correct
no for somebody if I have had a
Optometry license I don't think it's got
anything to do with that it's you can
address but I think there's an earlier
requirement in here related to that okay
if you can one one more followup just
would I mean I I this is this is not
related so the reciprocity stuff would
be in RSA 31017 and then the PLC 313 so
this is related
to
um it it doesn't really change the
meaning of the chapter of 32725 let so
there there is some restriction here on
um optometrists operating
businesses um retail businesses selling
contact
lenses and it's related to that issue
it's I mean that part where that change
is
[Music]
um okay it
it says the U the office um shall issue
a permit to such outof State businesses
which I believe are businesses that are
selling in the state in the state
correct and uh one of the requirements
is the business complies with all lawful
directions and requests for information
from the Board of Pharmacy and the board
of Optometry or other applicable
licensing authority of all states which
conducts business so if they're require
if they are asked to provide information
from from the licensing bodies in their
other the other states where they
operate um they have to provide it but
the issue is um that's not always called
a board or whatever so each state has
their own language and this allows for
that so in regards to the clarification
of that so if I'm ordering my contacts
or my glasses online after getting
evaluation done by the optometrist or
opthalmologist here
that business that mails
me that this holds to that those
businesses that are not practicing here
e-commerce and then I can go back to my
optometrist to or the opthalmologist to
clarify yes this is the right thing that
well I Mike I guess the question is look
at line eight uh seven and eight um for
the sale at retail of contact lenses to
individuals with the state does that
question I've never looked at that
question in detail but my understanding
would be if you're a business outside of
the state shipping into the state I
would think the answer would be yes okay
all right thank you yeah you know my
kids order contacts and glasses they get
the evaluation done here and they would
order online it's much cheaper to get it
that way but they would go back to their
eye doctor to make sure that's the right
one so representative
Brown thank you Mr chair so oplc permits
businesses as nothing to do with the
certification of optometrist and
opthalmologist in this section correct
thank
you any other
questions okay thank
you um if I may I yes I actually I
reviewed the new language on page seven
and I've got some recommended
changes okay there as well uh I'll just
go through them real quick on line seven
there's a floating and towards the end
of I that thank you um section B
establishment of an application process
under 31042 C the process lies with the
oplc so I would probably replace the
words and application process with the
word
criteria right keeping in line with the
board establishes the criteria the
office establishes the
process and I can give you my written
yeah that if you could actually email it
that would be great any others uh
sentence d uh same statute three 310
42c uh gives the office Authority around
the education so I I had stricken out
development of protocols for proctoring
and and I had left criteria for
requiring such proctoring that sentence
would obviously need to be tweaked we'd
have to probably Define proctoring I
think that came up earlier in testimony
that needs to be more clearly defined
and then in E uh implementation of an
outcome reporting I would change process
to requirements
because those would come in through the
office and then in section
two I had stricken the words on line 24
to the board of Optometry so that it
reads unless the op optometrist has
submitted evidence of satisfactory
completion and then I changed on line 25
board to office because that information
would come into
us okay thank you and if you could just
uh send an email with those details okay
I will do that okay thank you other
questions uh represent M py sorry after
this I'll be very quiet uh it's hard um
so with this the process you're clearly
dealing what is the process for oplc
what is the process for the board Ru
making requirement uh professional
requirement is set by the
board and uh oplc just focuses on
licensing
in the process correct would this in
your mind create a checks and balance to
see what the oplc is has another shot at
looking at what the applicant looks
like I I don't think we would be
establishing criteria in any way shape
or measure we would use the criteria
established by the board to make our
determinations and if it was a gray area
or if there was a question we would
bring that question to the board uh I
think my changes here simply keep keep
this bill in line with what we've done
in 655 409
Etc all right thank you representative
BR yeah I just I do want to make a
comment though because one of the things
that we did with House Bill
655 was um remove the um
subjectivity of applications of licenses
because what was happening was people
the board when they were doing this was
were interpreting
the um
applicant um depending on essay
questions and that brought bias and
subjectivity into it so by taking the
changing the criteria or making sure
that there are that it is um um
objective um that was part of the reason
why the the office is doing this OPP as
opposed to the board it SE it separates
them a little bit so there is it's I
wouldn't say it's a check and balance
but it's a more robust process and more
fair right right another way to look at
it which might help is that uh what's in
statute combined with what the boards
create through rul making provides the
rules of how licensing and complaints
and everything else is supposed to be
done and the office basically just is
the Machinery that carries it out based
on those rules but they're not making
policy decisions because that's in
that would give the legislative body to
hold the process or
the
indirectly to through oplc and through
the board that we have the oversight
responsib we're we're giving the board
The Authority where that they can do
rule making and then once that process
is done it's opl's job opl C's job to
carry it out anyone else
for this section not for this okay thank
you um the next section is actually at
the bottom of page seven the same page
and going into the next page and this is
um or is this the one I'd already
covered right that's the one sorry next
page page eight starting at line now we
already did that I'm off my page okay at
the bottom of page eight towards the
bottom
um I'm getting there
um in line um
34 this is uh regard to the requirements
for continuing
education
um in addition to those set by RSA 32733
and what what this
and
um what's on the next page including
line six
is
um some sort of rework to that so right
now there's
um I've got it here here yeah I've got
the well I'm looking actually at the
statute
um right now there the uh continued
education is broken up
into uh pharmaceutical versus
non-pharmaceutical
and then
also um gloma or
non-glaucoma and it it gets into how
that continuent education should be
split up and I think the general idea is
that that's should really be handled
through rul making I mean the statute
sets the the overall outline of that
that there needs to be some continuing
education uh but the details on it um
really shouldn't be in statute so what
this all does is it um it repeals 3 33
33a which is continued educations
required for pharmaceutical and glaucoma
certification and it changes 30 um
32733 to um just say uh continue
education courses required an
optometrist shall complete a minimum of
20 hours of contined Education by
participation in formal synchronous
courses each year in order to maintain
active licenses and there is I
3273 that's on Ru
making
um see I think there's something there
or or U else actually
it Roman 5 requirements for continue
education in addition to those
requirements set by RSA 32733 oh and
this needs to be well I got rid of the
reference to 33a uh in the repeal
so
um so basically through rulem the board
would set what are the requirements this
sets the overall amount but what are the
requirements what courses will meet the
requirements and that sort of thing so
any questions on
that okay representative Gro yeah
out so oh because okay because we're
amending different statutes it's all
kind of intermingled right all us may
change
order may change this to be more logical
yeah I I was I was amending I was
editing what was in place and right um
but uh yeah whe whether it's a separate
section and in whatever order um is is
so my question to you and maybe to
members
here has the continuing education
courses for 20 hours is that has that
been current
practice um well actually it was comp
you come up here but I I'll say
something first and and ask you to
answer that
um yeah it's a little actually why don't
you just answer so previously there were
separate classifications and there were
there was a group of optometrists that
were not prescribing medications that
only needed 15 hours we're now
simplifying that everybody will need the
20 hours the 20 hours of live formal
courses is what it has been all along um
again uh the SB 440 did eliminate in
from statute the board may still in Ru
making add other things but um there was
an additional 30 hours of strictly
independent study that was really not
trackable and so that was removed from
statute but the statute will remain that
it is 20 hours and it is increasing from
15 to 20 so that it's 20 for
everybody okay and is it if it's 20 for
everybody oh followup sorry followup if
it's 20 for everybody for these people
who would might be certified to do the
new procedure would there still be
it may supersede yes it may supersede
that the 20 is the minimum for everybody
and then the board can add additional
they may the board May specify when
they're doing these um the the ru making
for these procedures that some of that
20 might need to be in specific things
or they may need something beyond that
maintain okay so I'd like to beef that
up a little bit on the and and I'll try
to come up with some language because
the minimum of 20
hours just basically says that so we we
could put additional hours required for
within so it does specify that within
the new section that is being added 327
6D um that the board there would
establish minimum education for those
procedures so it does allow them there
that's within um the our new section 11
I'm sorry I don't have your current
draft to page number I've got to page 16
line 16 y page seven line 16 327 okay
okay1 and then the sub list it does
specifically indicate that they will
have education requirements specifically
for these procedures so that General 20
hours of education is for everybody
across the board but then maybe um
supplemented in R making okay I
understand yep as okay got it thank you
so much very
helpful okay so
um the uh that actually we've gone
through all of the proposed changes to
the bill so any other discussion on
this so one comment that I had are you
ask can I just jump in and take i i w
even raise my hand I'm so sorry um is
bill it
had what the bill did not
allow and I am I am I oh and I would
rather have it say what it allows I
think it has both okay it could it could
page three starting in line six yeah
it's got the practice of Optometry and
it lists the um you know part A lists
the things that they may do
and Part B lists the things that they
do um
and go jump in all right uh
representative he had asked earlier
representative Brown sorry go
ahead okay
yeah thank you Mr chair so
that's a question that I had based on
the on the 44 items in the back of one
of your books that optometrist were
looking to
do or the
220 codes that opthalmologists can
do is the way is the way this is written
now and and again we're all seeing this
first time this morning well not not
this part this is existing bill yeah no
I I understand that so the way that your
Amendment comes out the exemptions
there's only a certain number of
exemptions does that still mean that
autometers can do everything else if the
board or is it only if the board says
they can well first of all it's for them
to do anything it's got to be covered in
part A starting at line seven right now
those are are
General and by the way the I the
amendment I propos does not change this
section whatsoever that's in the
original Bill okay and and I guess I so
yes following up sir sorry certainly I I
that's one of my concerns
um we have to be clear on what is
allowed and what isn't allowed I guess
before the board gets to it because if
this
passes as it as whichever version if it
passes that be what is allowed or exempt
is irrelevant to Future rule making
would that be accurate uh no actually if
you can come first and we'll get
response again introduce yourself again
Yes again I'm Dr Angelique Sawyer um
North Conway H just a moment Simon had a
comment yeah if I could ask this just so
that you can cover it when you're
answering the question because I think
it'll kind of go in the same vein my
main concern with this section uh was
whether or not there was going to be
something that we're not considering at
the moment something that comes along in
the future um that isn't Exempted it
isn't in this list uh and what happens
with that when it comes up um you know
so is it going to be open for
optometrist to do that procedure simply
because it's not in the exclusion list
is that a possibility so the intention
and hopefully this this clarifies so the
the list of exclusions the board cannot
go beyond that so if something came
along that was for example um a retinal
procedure a retinal surgery that would
still not be something that Optometry
would be able to do um the new section
that is being added that 3276 D of those
bullet points the first one is
identification and categorization of the
Opthalmic procedures for the practice of
Optometry and so that is where the board
would specifically name those procedures
and so if something came along then a an
optometrist or someone would bring to
the board is this something that we're
able to do and it would go through rulem
to determine if that can be included in
the list that they're creating or
whether it is outside
and the the language in part one there
says that it must be consistent with
curriculum of nationally accredited
schools and colleges of Optometry so if
it is not something that is being taught
in an accredited school it is not
something the board would be able to do
excuse me where where were you sorry
that is all within um 3276 D um it was
number section 11 of the bill I don't
have line numbers I think it's on S no
it's it's um nope wrong copy that's the
original bill so of course I'm not going
to find it 11 but but what she's
referring to is on page seven page yeah
yes so so one the board is held only to
what is taught in the accredited schools
and colleges of Optometry so if nothing
something new comes along that is not
being taught that is not something the
board can allow the board in um sub item
a there has um identification and
categorization of the the procedures for
the practice of Optometry um and so that
is where the specific procedures would
be named rather than naming in statute
and having to come back and change
statute if a procedure had a change in
name or a subprocedure was developed the
board would be able to address through
rule
making Simon youe thank you yes and I
understand the process and thank you for
the clarification I guess my question is
more and for both sides actually is the
list exhaustive do does everybody see it
as exhaustive or is there something that
we might be missing that might pop up in
the future that's my concern that isn't
covered by any of the things that you've
said any of the caveats any of the
protections something that could fall
outside the realm of that because our
job is to close those things up before
it gets to the board I'm happy to let
the board do the board's thing but you
know we need to make sure that we've
done our due diligence on the front side
so Mr chair if anybody is able to
mention something that they don't think
is exhaustively covered in the list so
we could talk about that be helpful to
me this is the list of things that are
not
permitted right that's something that
should be added that is not in there
right something should be added to do
this list yes we are are open to adding
more exclusions if there's things that
anyone feels have been left off the
table that need to be included there
okay and before we go on anyse
representative BR did you have a
question okay because this is what so
I'm looking at page three of the thing
that everybody is looking at right now
which
has not changed from the original
bill which starts with okay at the top
section four practice of
otomet so all of these things are these
things like 1 2 3 4 and five have these
things are these things changing as a
result of this bill or the the things
that you've always done those in part A
items 1 2 3 four and five are things
that we've always done okay okay the
only uh change other than um because the
B was added they had it an A and then
change the headings I understand the the
other change is um removal of the the
words other than surgery in uh in a
which is which which is a big change
required for we're to which is why the
new section oh yes okay but then in B
and then we struck out F which is the
acute angle closure of glaucoma which we
heard as many times s Hearing I still
don't know what that is but we're you're
saying that you you are not going to
diagnose that we we can diagnose that um
so it it it specifically in the past
said that when it was diagnosed it then
required immediate referral to an
opthalmologist if the procedures are
permitted and the optometrist can
perform that laser surgery then that
referral to an opthalmologist
immediately in that moment it it would
would either go to an opthalmologist or
somebody who's able to perform that
procedure
okay go ahead representa Brown excuse me
I'm sorry yeah represent Brown I'm kind
of talking to myself I guess so that
strikeout on line 19 through 21 yes of
the
diagnosis then your ability to do that
falls back to number one yes that would
be included in number one yes exactly
thank
you okay I'm not I'm going finish with
he just jumped in that's okay that's all
right just
pausing I think you're a member of this
committee and I am not I'm an I'm an
interloper um from rep and then from
line 22 it shall not
mean the following and it lists all
these things that you cannot do and it
goes all the way to the next page yes
right
so is there anything else on this list
that's the point that we're trying to
that you are not you would not be able
to do based on your
training whether it's there there under
the criteria that we just established
yep um there may be things that are
outside of our training that our board
would not authorize to do that are not
necessarily excluded Ed here and if they
if that is the case it's an oversight
our attempt is to exclude things that
are not within our training right um but
because training is um continually uh
advancing um the the
board would limit
to only things that are within the
training and that are not excluded by
here and to my knowledge there are not
other procedures out there that we are
aiming to do that are not being
addressed by this or that the board is
not planning to list out in Ru making
ask
question thank you so according to this
any procedure that requires general
anesthesia you were not allowed to give
general anesthesia good okay and then
followup yes they are not correct
that is correct correct we are not able
to but you are do they give I don't know
like topical anesthesia to the eye
topical anesthesia yes and and would you
be trained for that
yes okay um I think that's it for right
now but but I still would like to have a
list of things that they can do because
you're saying that it's three laser
three
lasers something to do with a map can um
we we can share with you what the board
has drafted so far where that list is I
just got that from is
forming um okay because I think that
it's it rather oh yag not map yag that's
okay um so because there are surgeries
so let's just use the example of the
three lasers right how many I have no
idea how many lasers are there um Can
the laser that's used to do something
that you can do can it be used for
something that you can't do or are these
lasers process specific procedure
specific right they're there maybe now
and there may be development of other
uses for the lasers but they would not
we're not permitted to just freely use a
laser we are permitted for a specific
procedure by the board where they're
naming out this yag capsulotomy proced
procedure is what you would be able to
do and if that laser develops a new
purpose or a new use they would only be
able to do it once authorized by the
board once the board has included that
in the list of procedures that fall
under the
through so this is this is the part that
can that concerns me
because if for example I'm going to go
back to the Splinter all right let's say
even though it's a terrible analogy but
I can't think of anything
else the let's say the laser can REM can
remove the Splinter but then let's say
the the laser can fix the tendon in my
finger the same
laser so the person that owns the laser
can use it to take the splinter
out but then at what point
does Optometry
training enter a realm of
Opthalmology and their
training and at at one point because
obviously
opthalmologists study the eye as well
and they have
Specialties and they're trained for
those and you're trained for yours and
I'm going to even though it's an awful
analogy I'm also going to use a ladder
so you know you're you're stepping up
the ladder and is there are we at the
point is this bill and it sounds to me
that this does is that it overlaps some
of the responsibilities of The Optimist
and the
optometrist in those sections of
procedures that
are less grisky than others obviously if
your Reen is detached that's a big deal
and you know you got to go right but
does that mean that the width of that
band would grow with time I guess but
that's something that we have to you're
looking at me like no I'm looking at
Tony no no no I'm I'm trying to get
understand I'm trying I guess my concern
is that a good investigation it's I just
I'm going to call it capability creep
doesn't go beyond your capability and
how do we safeguard that absolutely so
in your example with the Splinter and
then the laser could do something
more there are procedure codes removal
of that splinter is one procedure repair
of the tissue or going down into the
tendon or doing something different is
another procedure okay that makes sense
so so through procedure codes um is
where the board would be identifying
these are the things that are approved
um through that part A of the
identification of procedures okay okay
any other qu um but I saw hands and when
we're done with questions for this
person I'll let somebody else on the
other side respond we know or comment um
he had asked representative Brown and
then representative M boy and most or
gold and then M yep thank you Mr chair
so for everyone my my concern about this
is that I don't
understand how let's use a simple
example in a residency for an
opthalmologist how many times have you
used a scalpel on a live person to
practice a
procedure and for an optometrist that
wants to do that same procedure that has
never had that amount of training
how can you guarantee me to me that you
will get that before you do that
procedure I I don't even know what the
numbers are so um the we I believe we
have the acgme chart of the procedures
and the number of
codes um if we have not provided that we
can we can get that um they have a long
list of of requirements and we've
highlighted the only four procedures on
that list that we would be anticipating
doing that are the rest are excluded by
the list of
exclusions and okay and and to follow up
I let me try a more General answer and
then you can ask anything to Follows so
the section on page
um that they're not allowed to to do any
procedure unless they you know the the
board is going to has rul making they're
required to do rule making to categorize
theic procedures into presumably groups
so they're not dealing with every one of
these things yeah and then they um will
establish criteria to uh for
certification to perform those
procedures and establish a minimum
education training and live experience
requirements for certification perform
such procedures I guess that's my
question and and that's and that's
rulemaking and if they perform the
procedure without that certification
that's a disciplinary offense but that's
too late well sorry but that's too late
for the patient I mean you can't any
what you're saying is anyone can break
the law and we can't how do you prevent
someone from breaking the law ahead of
time in any realm all you can do is is
provide deterrence and deal with the
case where it happens at least that's my
take represent groa
I I just want to make a comment about
this
because I do believe that people in the
healthc care industry care about people
yeah and they're not going to just like
I would not remove a splinter from you
know my finger because I am not I would
not feel qualified to do
that most
people if they have any Humanity at all
are going to care about a procedure on
someone's eye on whether or not they're
qualified I mean my goodness have we do
we have such a low opinion of our own
professions and our own individuality
that we would think something like that
I hope not and and actually a related
question related to that is I think you
mentioned before but I believe the
training for optometrist and I'm sure
for optomologist includes some uh
training on the issue of Ethics is that
not correct 100% yes we take an oath to
we we take an OP metric oath to care for
our patients and that includes ethics
within the
oath okay
um yes repr I'm gold y thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so what I'm trying to get my head around
is the lists of prohibited and the lists
of permitted and and
particularly first of all let me say
what I love about this process is I
think it's been an incredible
educational process for everybody about
how these systems work and and what our
role is and what everybody else's role
what the boards do Ru making all of that
both for some people in the audience and
for some of the newer committee members
but what I'm struggling with here
statutes set up in a way that allows the
board to exercise the kind of
professionalism that I think
representative groda just laid out
ethics Integrity
professionalism and not bind our boards
to having to come back to this body and
us to have to listen to and educate the
next reiteration of
fearful
public and professionals why why do we
have to have these exact list lists in
here is this
because
there's turf or fear things going on
that we're having to
protect the obstacles that have been
discussed I'm trying to understand why
these specific items need to be in this
bill why the exclusions need to be there
yeah and also the permissi so the the
exclusions are there for reassurance
I believe that if these exclusions were
not here in the statute the board would
still Implement these exclusions because
these are not within our Education and
Training um but at this point we wanted
to leave in statute where those who have
concerns about this can see that there
are still parameters that the board has
to operate within including things that
we know are not in the Education and
Training of any optometrist at this
point so those are being excluded and
then giving the board The Authority
outside of those exclusions to within
Education and Training and within a very
thorough rul making procedure to prove
the education to prove that it's being
taught in accredited schools to prove
that there is live experience and if
there's a procedure that we can't get
live experience then that's a procedure
that we may not be doing that the board
may not be able to authorize so thank
you follow up so follow um I like the
idea
of the the more General I guess is the
right way to say it the more um or
procedural coverage if it's trained by
an accreditated school what I'm
concerned about is on the exclusion list
and and I trust you you know this I
don't want to know this I don't want to
become an expert in your
Fields um are you really certain that
this list of exclusions is not something
that is going to we've talked about the
training the educational facilities are
going to be uh upping their game as
we're breaking new ground in allowing
more procedures to be done by you all
are you confident that these should be
on that list I I am confident that at
this point and for the foreseeable near
future for what is being taught in
schools at this point that these
exclusions um are are not going to
create more barriers
thank you and for as a Native American
uh the next seven generations are we
look at so thank you thank you uh you
still have a represent M py thank you Mr
chair thank you for um taking my
question again I will go to page three
line
22 it says shall not mean the following
Opthalmic surgery procedures except for
the pre-operative and postoperative care
which means there is a collaborative
effort to work with the
opthalmologist
and does that
still work in the it it's a team effort
right super specialty should not become
more
siloed and so would this
ensure that the optomet and the
Opthalmology can still coexist and work
collaboratively for a better outcome and
safety for all who need the care in I
can only address it for the granite
state I I certainly hope so I certainly
I have very valuable trusted
relationships with providers that I
refer to and that I'm going to need to
continue to refer to um and I um want
all of them to know that that trust will
continue to be there there may be some
of these procedures that are excluded
that we don't provide even the pre- and
postoperative care of because that's
beyond our expertise and that they are
best in those risky complicated
situations staying with that surgeon for
even the pre- and postoperative Care um
but this does leave it open for when
there is the the mutual relationship
there and the the optometrist can
provide pre- and post operative Care at
the surgeon's discretion we want that to
continue and we we hope that that will
sides you r i i i i look I read that
language very carefully and it's it's I
mean it's just perfectly obvious that if
you are a an eye person okay and you
look at the person's eye and you say wow
you're going to need something more that
I can't do that's Prett pre operative
you're going like holy hell get Dr X on
the line okay and once you've had the
procedure then the that you're you're
looking at their eye about something
completely different later that's all
postoperative I mean it's just as
obvious as you know don't dive off the
pool until the diving board without
checking for water in the pool you know
so let me let me kind of expand on that
and actually ask a question and that is
are there some procedures that
opthalmologists do today where they work
with optometrist to do at least some
part of the preoperative and
post-operative care that's planned
that's not if a problem is found yes um
cataract surgery is the most common
particularly in my area my surgeons are
an hour away from the Berlin office so
um if you need cataract surgery you are
traveling um when it is a
straightforward case that the surgeon is
comfortable with me taking over the
postoperative care they do not need to
go back to their surgeon for their
follow-ups um and so that is that is a
very common practice throughout the
state both pre and postoperatively okay
thank you any other questions for Dr
Sawyer all right oh wait represent groa
thank you um on okay so going to the
part where it
says we're pre-operative and
postoperative care of and it says retina
laser procedures penetrating care to PL
y or qu all those F from a to F do you
assist now on these for some of them yes
not all of them um
sorry uh most commonly we do pre- impost
operative care for refractive surgery um
we do uh pre- and postoperative Care um
if uh you if somebody has had a corneal
transplant usually they're going to stay
pretty close to their surgeon for a
while but there does come a point where
they are transferred back to their
optometrist um usually if it's a
procedure that has required general
anesthesia the majority of that um
follow-up care that postoperative care
is likely going to be held close to the
surgeon so um but but some of these
yes follow and I don't see cataract
surgery here is that um under subsection
the um part two the following non- laser
surgery
the um line f is extraction of the
crystalline lens and G is surgical
interocular implants okay got it thank
you any other questions for uh Dr
s okay thank you and if one person um
and some opthalmologist would like to
section yes I do um the blue books so
that's this thing yeah and yeah please
introduce
yourself hi my name is Anthony KY I'm an
opthalmologist at New Hampshire ey
Associates in Manchester thank you for
giving me opportunity to speak today um
so a couple of things on the
exclusionary wrist I I know it's a
confusing part of the language in the
bill and we we found it equally
confusing our initially our panel had
looked at that exclusionary list
identified over 250 Opthalmic procedures
that uh would be permissible under the
statute
we spoke with the optometrist and they
provide us a list of 44 which is in the
very back section of your blue book it's
in a yellow it's highlighted in yellow
so the green part is what they can do
now uh it's the very back page 36 36
anybody else need one
good um so in that if there's any
question about what they're asking to do
now we were tasked with the uh with the
uh my speaker Packer to look at each one
of these and decide if it was anything
we could permit optometrist to perform
and in your sen I I'd like to correct
your language you're not in a position
to permit or not permit anything okay my
apologies yeah um uh he asked us to uh
look at the procedure list and comment
um in that list he we identified four uh
we find identified four procedures that
we identified as safe and minor um with
regards to the exclusionary list though
I do want to get back to it because it
is an interesting uh topic and we were
looking at other other organizations or
other uh governing boards in New
Hampshire including podiatrist
and um dentistry and when you look at
their governing board you look at their
scope of practice they Divine as
inclusionary so for example Podiatry if
you look at their inclusionary language
and I won't go through the whole um
whole statute but it defends it as
surgical means and ailments of the human
foot and lower leg so the analogy here
and the concern we have is that you're
almost saying like a podiatrist well you
you can't do the head you can't do the
chest you can't do the
abdomen well does that mean you can do
the hip does that that mean you can do
the knee it's a it's a confusing part CU
in our world this is say saying the same
thing here that where there's so many
unknowns as to how many procedures will
be allowed by sen up Bill 440 um excuse
me that's number one I wanted to go back
if we could to the uh uh the uh first of
all I I appreciate your folks putting
the time into this we've only seen this
new Amendment for about an hour and a
half so we're kind of going through it
here and I apologize um if I if I
misspeak but uh the the uh exoskeleton
uh that was disced
um there was a mention of the acgme
requirements um were utilized I guess as
part of that I do want to mention about
the acgme in in their statute or in
their in their rules they they do Define
minimum numbers represent what the RW
committee believes to be an acceptable
minimal experience minimum numbers are
not a final Target number and
achievement does not signific uh exuse
me signific signify competence so in
other words the the acgm accredits these
residency programs with a minimum
standard but it's actually up to The
Residency program director to um
determine
competency uh with regards to surgical
residency programs and Optometry we're
still a bit confused by this uh I I know
they have residency programs but I you
know to to say that there's a equivalent
to an Opthalmology Residency program
where they're accredited whether they're
licensed me Li uh accredited mentored uh
and have a minimum case number I we we
don't we have not seen that to exist and
we don't feel that the you know equating
the quinal residency programs that are
exist now are similar to the surgical
residency programs that we go through in
terms of accreditation in terms of
minimal surgical uh
volume and uh yeah lastly I I have to
look at the exoskeleton details more
more uh closely but the uh I I think it
would be very hard to to create recreate
The Residency experience with you know
anything that wasn't mentored you know
that wasn't supervised that didn't have
live patient experience and I I haven't
looked at the details but I I look
forward to hearing more about it so ly
and that's all I wanted to say today all
right all I'd say is that um you know in
uh uh what's uh the new part new 327 6D
um it it requires
um you know live experience and it
requires um that they're going to be um
it says proctoring the language may
change but basically or we need actually
need to talk about that but uh you know
they're not just going to be having
these live EXP experiences on their own
without somebody watching what they're
doing and directing what they're doing
um so that's in there and um and the
board is charged with rulemaking for the
details of all of these so that before
any optometrist can do any of this that
has to be completed and um I mean I
suspect I I'm not that familiar with the
uh bard of meeses any Board of Medicine
statutes that are directly related to
opthalmologists but correct me if I'm
wrong but are the details of um criteria
for opthalmologists do any particular
procedure uh laid out in statute no they
are not I right and uh I don't even know
if they're laid out in
rules yeah our competency comes from the
The Residency experience and having uh
essentially passing the test of three
years of residency that's where our I
guess our I think because at least at
this point with optometrist and I you
know if I'm misstating something let me
know that
that isn't fully developed because it
couldn't be because many states would
not permit it um the you know the
requirement is that the board and again
everybody will have input on this rul
making the board is directed to provide
Ru making on this and you know as
they've expressed it they'll presum be
guided by um you know the optometrist
certification organization now and also
for the other procedures by the uh the
one for the
opthalmologists and then you know and
that even that's just um you know and
set the minimums for that
so anyway that's that's it's it's
not there's more to it I think than than
you seem to be indicating in which
saying that's my only point on that um
um so uh represent groa uh Brown and MTI
unless there's somebody else so on your
in this book some of these proposed
codes are are in yellow and some are in
green why is that the green is what they
are uh by Statute allowed to do now and
the yellow is what they are uh asking
right and when you negoti when this this
whole one of the reasons why we there
was supposed toly a negotiation between
so what of these yellow ones were you
going to did you concede that would be
okay um if you go to the introduction
section so if you go to page uh it is
Page four of the booklet yeah uh the
four CPT code listed at the top of that
booklet so four yes out of the out of
the
44 yeah we convened a panel of ocul
plastics uh corne and glaucoma
specialist to review that thoroughly
okay thank
you okay any other questions actually
there were some others or brown okay
thank you Mr chair so you may be you may
not be able to answer this but maybe
someone else
can uh as you go through a surgical
residency obviously you have X amount of
hours and you do all this
work if you don't get if an optometrist
for example didn't get the amount of
practice uh for particular surgical
techniques how is that going to happen
afterwards you're out of school you're
now an optometrist how do you get that
Hands-On where do you go to get that
Hands-On patient live patient work I
think that could most appropriately be
answered by uh Dr Sawyer or someone on
that side because
yeah yes I mean to answer that we're not
aware of any accredited uh surgical
residencies in Optometry that and as as
Dr CLE had mentioned you know that there
is no minimum quote unquote minimum uh
at the testimony he metion there's no
minimum either but we're not aware of
any accredit that you can equate to a
Opthalmology surgical residency that
exists yeah well we'll get someone else
up to
no and I and I I understand I understand
that for sure thank you um someone
else
uh represent
Mony thank you uh Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question um again I'll go back to the
section where it
says shall not mean the following
optomic surgery procedures except for
the pre-operative
postoperative So
currently there are many practices many
hospitals and private
practices like Nashi Associates there
are 10
optometrist 14
opthalmologists with oil specialty
working together right yes including my
practice yes
so do you see any op obstacle because
for me it's important that we don't
create more
silos saying you know I'm left thumb
specialist so I don't you know I only do
this the super Specialties started with
the intention of working as a team so I
am seeing some or is it my own
perception that I'm seeing that thing
this is my territory this is your
territory the territorial thing where
the patient is going to be compromised
not getting the much needed care at this
time is do you see anything like that
with this if this bill passes with all
the Amendments with all the
inclusions I I go back to the you know
again this the the exoscale was
mentioned I I go back to you know what
we we know is the you know the standard
in in Opthalmology is the you know
certified res uh residency experience
17,000 hours mentored uh with you know
minimum standards and and display of
Competency um and I I would I would
would be uh you know lying to if I
didn't say if that if there was a a
pathway we just don't see I don't see a
a similar model set up that would allow
that level of of of um of um training in
in in the in in the current
system follow with that just that one
follow up yeah so this is it says it's
not doing this surgery it's pre and post
care they might not even optometrist may
not even do the pre and post care is
there room for that collaboration to say
you know optometrist can bring it up to
this level with the current education
with the current technology iCal uh
advancements in the field of Opthalmic
procedures just if I take just the
contacts it used to be that hard glass
you have to take clean it now you can
wear it for 30
days yeah in the relationship has always
been very collaborative I I I I don't
discount that I mean the Optometry and
our practice see medic managed medical
diseases they they medically managed
glaucoma and it's extremely
collaborative I I think the analogy
earlier was that that ladder that we
were talking about like how far up the
ladder and I you know we you know we'
we've we've said before that you know
when the you know surgical when you're
talking about lasers and surgery you
know potentially you know blinding
procedures here where their margin of
error is so small it it really requires
a a level of experience and and and
surgical training that you know again we
we we do in
residency all right um at this point I
think we're going to take a short caucus
the uh
uh representative Brown and Bailey we're
going to go in the office there and
representative Gro where you want to go
so we'll be back I I don't expect and
everybody
e
on uh Senate Bill
440 and um I'm going to make a
motion which is that we accept the
amended language um that I sent out have
to have an actual official um Amendment
drafted by OS for before next Wednesday
and with um the technical language
changes that were requested by oplc for
um the section 327 6D just to make clear
what's the responsibility the board
versus um the
office and um there may be some uh
technical changes the exact descriptions
of some items on the exclusionary list
and um and those would be in there as
well but that that's what I'm that's
what the motion is um do I have a
second okay clarification Mr
chair yeah so well actually I'll you're
making a motion for an amendment that
will have all the changes that we
discussed as an amendment corre not as
an amended bill that we have right now
um all right I'm just making some notes
here and then all right
so and this is uh just the members
official members of the sub committee to
vote um all who are in favor discussion
or well actually we can have some
discussion if you like sorry any
discussion yes thank you Mr chair so uh
we talked about this obviously in the
back
room um I'm oh we can't no you can't
talk about happening con no no it's a
secret I'm not telling you rules rules
rules yeah I'm going to vote for this
with the understanding from
representative Simons back of the room
conversations and and the way I believe
the bill reads after having a
conversation that the live experience
requirements that will come through rul
making however that works however you're
going to get your live
experience will protect Public Safety by
not
allowing anyone to do these procedures
it's not that's not
qualified thank you Mr chair right and I
think that's pretty clear in statute U
on if they're told they can't do it and
if they do there's disciplinary action
so I think that will assure that any
other discussion represent maputi um I
will support the amended
version with the understanding that the
collaborative effort between the
opthalmologist and the optometrist will
enhance not create more isolation so the
collaborative effort
that would benefit the granite
Staters to get the best possible Care at
the best
most as quickly as possible and as
reasonably as possible so that's with
that intention with that
understanding I will support this thank
you I I share the same expectations
anyone
else okay um all
do I get to say something I I think okay
at this point like lunch time um all in
favor I anyone
opposed okay um the next moot I need a a
motion for otpa which I can make or
someone else can okay um otpa ought to
pass with the amendment and that's uh
representative Gould and brown
representative G would you like to speak
to your motion I think we've said
everything we need to say representative
Brown uh I agree with that okay all in
favor oh discussion okay sorry so this
will come to our full committee next
week so we'll have the amendment and
with the vote and I I will um add the
minor changes we discussed I will send
this off to all us get an amendment I'll
take a quick look to make sure they did
it correctly and then I'll send it out
to the full committee thank you um as
soon as I I get it um any other
discussion okay all in favor I anyone
opposed okay I'm going to close the
subcommittee work session on Senate Bill
440 thank you everyone both on this side